I don't people I asked you on twitter if
you have any questions for me and
apparently there's a lot of things that
you guys want answered it's at Rubin
report uh on Twitter right there no the
on the Twitter machine and let's do it
here we go at me to Ryan 817 if you had
to make love to a golden girl who would
you choose and why I did a lot of
thinking about this I've been asked this
question before in more forums than you
can possibly imagine and uh I'm going I
notice a little cliche but I would have
to say Blanche because the wealth of
experience that she has uh the things
that she could do uh we know that she's
been able to have sex on a crappy is
there was an episode where that sort of
happened it was implied it was gonna
happen there was a mirror above her bed
I mean she's done things and if I'm
gonna do it with a woman who's in her
sixties although she claims she's in her
forties I feel like I'd want a lot of
tricks and things involved next uh Eric
Wallace 117 anyone from Fox News you'd
like to interview um this is actually
funny because I've been saying this a
lot lately I I'm sort of fascinated by
megan kelly she is so stone-cold focused
like a frickin laser when you're
watching her it's like you cannot stop
making eye contact with her and she so
believes everything she's saying whether
it's true or not um that I'm really kind
of fascinated by her and I would love to
sort of sit there and see if I could
break through uh because i actually
think she's a very good television
personality uh but what most cable news
people need is a little humanity and i
think that that's what the online world
is doing a little bit better when I hope
we're doing a little bit better and I'd
like to see if I could kind of break
that facade but in terms of someone just
do in their job and doing it effectively
and messaging and all that stuff she
gets across I'm really fascinated by her
okay what's next is there an I in team
that's chef by one no there is no int
might try to apply that to my life all
the time especially when I'm playing
basketball next Buick 59 when is this to
be aired or blog or whatever tickets on
right now okay what's next you Sookie
420 why do you think face-to-face
interaction is so important if we could
simply read each other's minds would
that not be better you know this is one
of things we talked about on the show
all the time two weeks ago we did a show
with Chad I'm binder and Kelly Carlin we
talked a lot about you know the iphone
in the digital stuff we're all walking
with our head down it's changing
people's necks and we've done stories on
how all this digital stuff is changing
people's brain chemistry and I see it
all the time attention spans and you're
in a conversation with someone they
start looking down literally in the
middle of the thought people are
forgetting what they're saying all the
time um so do I think reading people's
minds would be better that that might be
a bit much but I do think a little more
a little more one-on-one uh I'm doing
I'm trying i said this many times and
I'm doing the best I can I'm trying to
shut down the phone by like nine o'clock
and not look at it I'm try not to grab
it right when I wake up all that kind of
stuff because we do need more human
interaction because you know you look
even if you look on Twitter uh you see
these people professional people that
are that are out there uh authors and TV
people in bed regular people they're
just fighting all day long and an
arguing with people in ways that they
would never do that in person and i
think it's it's a lot of nonsense and uh
a little human interaction humanizes you
what's next uh Frederick's Matt do you
support scotlands independence or should
they stay part of the UK so I think the
vote is going down today am i right is
it today anyone anyone anyone the boats
going down today possibly tomorrow from
when we're taping this um you know what
I know a lot about politics and and the
world and all this stuff and this is one
thing every now and again there's like
one little thing that for a couple
months kind of slides under my radar and
I haven't really done my due diligence
on this one so but my gut feeling and
again I'm not a professional in this
part of the world my gut feeling is that
this union has lasted for a long long
time right color hundreds of years and
that once you start separating people
they're just going to find more ways for
for hate and arguments and war and all
that stuff so that being said if the
people of Scotland if that's really what
they want as I say all the time
everybody has the right to
self-determination and if they think
that's better for their future than I
suppose they should do that but the
general idea that this thing is existed
for so long
you know hopefully that can that can
continue I suppose that's probably not a
great answer what do you think or what
are you guys watching this thing let me
know right down below and I believe we
have one more not Sam why are you so
handsome well coming from Sam who I've
had on the show Sam Roberts from Sirius
XM very handsome fella that is that is
quite a compliment and it's just a lot
of creams there's a lot of creams and I
got this new hair wax that's that's
pretty much it's smoked America